what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder and today at San
Diego Comic-Con Marvel has revealed the
entire phase five slate and it has some
really really exciting projects and it
tells us exactly when phase four ends
and when phase five begins and when
phase five also ends so let's not waste
any time let's jump right into Marvel's
phase five alright so Marvel phase four
actually ends with She-Hulk and black
panther will come to Forever this is
just a little bit more than they showed
us when they revealed phase four
previously but that was pre-pandemic now
this is post so essentially phase four
ends this year but before we dive into
phase five they first gave us a huge
reveal they actually gave us a first
look at Charlie Cox's Daredevil who is
going to be in the She-Hulk series and
they did confirm this and gave us this
still if you can take a look here it's
actually the yellow Daredevil suit not
the red one but the yellow one and
although this is just a slight tease I
am super super pumped for Daredevil to
be in the m to you for Charlie Cox to be
playing Matt Murdock once again and
Phase 5 starts with Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania coming out February 17th
of 2023 and we did get a new poster
reveal for Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania showing Scotland's daughter Cassie
Lane suited up in her Pim suit most
likely going to betray the character
stature like she does in the comics and
we also got a new look at Jonathan
Majors as king the Conqueror if you take
a look in the upper left here then
coming in the spring of 2023 is going to
be Marvel's secret Invasion following
that is going to be Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 coming out on May 5th then
we have in the summer of 2023 the echo
series coming which should also have
Daredevil in it as well coming up next
summer of 2023 is going to be Loki
season 2. then on July 28th of 2023
we're going to get the Marvels then we
have an official date for blade November
3rd 2023 next year now fall of 2023 we
are going to be getting the Iron Heart
series then in the winter of 2023 or
2024 Marvel Studios has not yet decided
on which year we get Agatha coven of
chaos as the official title then and
this is a big one of spring in 2024 we
get Daredevil Born Again Charlie Cox
returns in his own series that is going
to be 18 episodes long and like we
showed before we got a little bit of a
sneak peek of his new suit then here's
another big one on May 3rd of 2024 where
you're getting Captain America new world
order this of course is going to be with
Sam Wilson's Captain America and I'm
really excited to see it and then we
have the Thunderbolts we finally have an
official announcement from Marvel
Studios that the Thunderbolts is indeed
confirmed it is in development right now
it is coming out July 28th of 2024 and
that will actually end Marvel's phase
five so here it is Phase five of the MCU
officially confirmed with dates I will
be doing a bunch of breakdowns about
this in the upcoming days so be sure to
subscribe hit that notification Bell so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
videos and follow me on Instagram and
Twitter for live updates as always thank
you all so much for watching wolf wolf